[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
within
two weeks we will face the most
important election of our lifetimes
and we hear this every single election
we hear it's always the most important
election
of our lifetimes but just because we
always hear it doesn't mean it isn't
true
and uh joining us now is one of the
great political observers
of the trump administration generally
speaking also but
especially at this political moment the
author of the flight 93 essay
which gave basically the intellectual
framework
to trumpism former national security
official and the trump administration
lecturer at hillsdale college senior
fellow at the claremont institute
and the author of the stakes new book
out from regnary america
at the point of no return mr michael
anton mike thank you so much for coming
on
thank you so i got to tell you i loved
the book it was
really really good all of your writing
is really great i mean i encourage
everybody to go out and you can read
your claremont review and
at american mind and all over the place
however i got to tell you it's not the
most uplifting read
i was waiting for this very exciting you
know wonderful hopeful everything's
going to be fine
that's not quite the vision that you see
well i i
it does have a happy ending chapter
eight is meant to be an upper that's
granted after seven chapters of downers
um
to say look we can we can get our way
out of this politically economically
socially
it won't be easy but it's possible and i
lay out a bunch of things that i think
we ought to do
um i think you know beginning with
trump's got to win this election
he's got to have a successful second
term but i don't want to
you know um shine anybody on into
thinking
or that well that's all we have to do we
win this election four more years manga
drain the swamp it's all fixed by 2024.
it's not all going to be fixed by 2024.
no matter how
successful trump's second term is
there's just we we spend
you know depending on when you start
counting you can start counting at the
beginning of the progressive era that's
125 years you could start with the 60s
so that's a half a century we spent a
long time
digging ourselves in this hole we're not
coming out of it in in four or even
eight years
you've got a unique perspective here
because you you've got the granular
level i mean you actually did work in
the white house
and then you've got this much broader
historical and philosophical and
academic level here so for people who
haven't yet read the book
what are the stakes both in terms of the
nitty-gritty you know
highly detailed policy issues and then
the broader philosophical problems that
the country faces
um i mean nitty gritty is essentially
whether the country will be turned into
a blue state from sea to shining sea
a continental california sort of
so to speak where there's no effect of
opposition where
there may be an opposition party and
opposition people but they have no power
they can't do anything and
and the people in power have no reason
to pay any attention to them or
compromise with them i
fear that's the nitty-gritty stakes and
then once the left comes in what will
they do well
some of it they've already told us that
a lot of it they hint at
some of it they keep secret you know and
you know spring it on you when they're
ready to do it um
for instance you know they they are just
a small thing but they spent the whole
2018 campaign saying yeah we're not you
know
impeachment what are they impeachment
we're not serious and then as soon as
they got in there
that became priority priority one um
and i think worse in a way than uh
california from
than what california is now because
california is still
in a sense uh constrained in what it can
do
by the reality of the fact that there
are red states and there are red
senators and there isn't
checks within the federal government and
in our system that prevents it from
being quite as progressive as it wants
to be
when those balance those last breaks are
removed i think you'll see
leftism go into a kind of hyperdrive
that the left has been dreaming about
for a long time but hasn't been able
to implement it so that's the and you
know on the
more macro level the stakes are i i will
use this language which sounds a little
bit hyperbolic but kind of blue woke
tyranny for as long as they can keep it
going
and that could be 10 years or 20 or 50
or 100 i don't honestly know
there are lots of reasons to believe
they'll have a hard time keeping it
going i lay all of those out in chapter
six
but then there are reasons you know such
as improved technology
pharmaceuticals all kinds of things that
prior tyrants didn't have
that the the current left has at their
disposal or to a greater degree
that maybe make this new situation
unprecedented
uh and i i hear a lot from people
it's a fair point they say the soviet
union lasted 70 years
70 years is you know in historical terms
you could even say a fairly
short time for a big imperial tyranny
you know that's not you know some of the
ancient tyrants sort of scoffed and said
70
these are bikers right now it's very
long time if you have to endure it
um could we could could this thing that
may be coming for us
last longer than that i don't i don't
know
but i i would hate to have the finding
out
happen because of the experience you
know what i mean the only way i used to
i say to my students when we're talking
about
nuclear issues so i teach national
security the thing about nuclear war is
you can gain theory at all you want but
at the end of the day the only way to
test your theory is in an actual
practice
and if you get to that point you lost
that's right you don't you don't need to
see that you know no one desires to see
that even if we say in historical terms
70 years isn't that long
70 years is pretty much a lifetime you
know and if it happens to fall on your
lifetime
then you're gonna have a much more
difficult life
where did this begin i mean everyone
knows there's something that's gone
horribly wrong everyone knows that we
are not
governed in the way that the
constitution says that we ought to be
governed but
but i think people disagree on where it
begins is it because of
the cultural revolutions of the 60s is
it because of the progressive era is it
because
democrats are manipulating the vote
through open borders and mass migration
or is it some other issue as well i mean
where where do you find the
the problem really lies so the real the
the
academic dork in me will say look if you
want to get to the ultimate source of it
it's in
um false pernicious and corrupted
philosophic
doctrines buried in the structure of
modernity itself
right and this is what leo strauss's
work he was my not my teacher because he
died when i was too young but i
i was taught by his students where he
tries to revive
um just the wisdom of plato aristotle
cicero and the ancients who
see reality for what it is but without
these
doctrines that really start and then you
get you get into various questions
about how bad are the early moderns
really but
certainly by the time you're getting
into the mid 18th century
the philosophic doctrines go sideways
and intent
intensify in their perniciousness now i
in the book i trace our
present um quandary to three
basic causes interrelated causes one is
the doctor ironically the doctrine of of
john c calhoun and southern secessionism
not to attack the south not to make it
you know or certainly not to make a kind
of
proposition nationist well but the idea
that
of calhouns of group rights uh what do
you call a concurrent majority that
rights do not inhere in the individual
but they adhere in a body
a group which essentially the point of
that is to allow minorities political
minorities to overrule lawful majorities
that has ironically been taken up by the
woke left who now say you know they care
nothing about the individual rights
philosophy of the american founders
borrowed from john locke et cetera but
they do believe that demographic
categories
have rights and privileges that ought to
be that ought to enable them to overrule
majority will that's point one it's uh
odd that calhoun finds himself on the
same side as ibrahim x candy
i think if you could if you could first
of all calhoun would i'm sure the name
would and alone would shock him and then
you explain to him he's this kind of
dumb guy he teaches the university jack
twitter recently gave him 10 million
dollars
but basically his whole theory is your
theory except he's flipped the races
wow uh and then the second is
progressivism
with the capital p which is a very mixed
bag in that um the
the practical side this is a movement
that begins in the late 19th century
and gains political power in the persons
of
woodrow wilson teddy roosevelt hiram
johnson the governor of california
so it's popular in both parties
especially among experts
the good side of progressivism is that
they were patriotic and that most of
what they were trying to do were good
things so the progressives give you the
civil serve you know
um civil service exam and they get
corruption out of the civil service they
build the national park system
they lead the way eventually on
immigration reform
they do all kinds of things that are
actually extremely beneficial to the
nation
the problem is the basis on which they
do it they make an argument that attacks
the constitutional foundations of the
republic
their argument is essentially to use a
modern analogy they say
um you know the we have this
think of a computer and it's software
right the nation is the computer
the constitution the declaration is the
software they look at it and they say
okay
in 1776 we were basically running a
commodore 64.
so this crummy old whatever the code was
then worked fine
now we have a big sun microsystems
mainframe
and it's super big and complex and we're
still running the same software code
outdated we gotta update it more or less
we gotta update it all the time
right so they attack the constitution
they attack the principles of the
declaration as being
maybe adequate for the 1700s definitely
not adequate now and have to be scrapped
going forward because they're too
limiting
and that critique of the constitutional
and moral
philosophical foundations of the of the
american government has really never
gone away it's been now
part of the intellectual mainstream for
125 years
and to the point where people argue law
professors and others argue openly in
the new york times the constitution is a
problem just the other day
somebody wrote in the new york times the
first amendment is a problem all of this
kind of comes out of the progressive era
and then the third
tranche i think is what you said that
60s cultural revolution
which i can't recommend i know or i'm
supposed to be plugging my own book
but i can't recommend highly enough
chris caldwell's book yeah where he says
when people pass the civil rights
reforms of the 60s
what they're told they're doing and what
they think they're doing is we're
removing unjust barriers
once those and we we never should have
had these in the first place it's
terrible but
maybe this it's it's it's you know
should have gotten it never should have
happened the first place should have
gotten
them a long time ago but we're doing it
now we're abolishing this
we're never going to do this again we
recognize its horribleness and now we're
going to live life as a real country
with this thing finally behind us
what what really happened though that's
what people thought they were getting
but what they got was a complete
inversion
of the old constitution both in terms of
the regime itself and how it functions
but also that as you put it
cultural revolution that comes out of
the 60s and you know it takes a while so
1975 already looks fairly different than
1965 but not
as different um the longer you go the
more you see this
the kind of wokeness and stuff showing
up but it also is
it's self-accelerating so i went to
college in the late 80s and early 90s
a lot of what we are talking about today
in 2020 was
very popular on college campuses then i
mean it was
starting to bubble to the surface and
and receive pushback and i think there
was a sense in the rest of the country
that
yeah that's stupid but you know it's
called what do you expect i mean it's
berkeley you know
they're going to be the way they are um
we don't have to worry about this in
in real life in real america well takes
a while but eventually
you do and you did and now it's it's
upon us in every
sector the things that were considered
kooky fringe
only college campus since hyper left
college towns in
1990 are now mainstream
mandatory doctrine everywhere this is
the the line that drives me craziest is
when the kind of more squishy
conservatives or complacent
conservatives
will say oh don't worry about those
nutty blue hairs on college campus
once they get out into the real world
then they're going to find out their
ideas are crazy and i have to tell you
i'm in the real world a lot
the real world is starting to look a lot
more like the college campus
than than as recently as
five years ago you would hear i was
hearing
you know voices on the left who are
about my age who are fighting the same
kind of culture war arguments that i've
been fighting one way or another
they were saying you know what i think
we might have gone too far like we
we didn't pay attention to what we were
teaching kids but they came at it from
the following angle their thought was
the colleges the colleges have really
gotten stupid yeah and people who are
going to get hurt are the kids who think
they're getting an education who are
then going to go out into the quote
unquote real world and
get eaten alive and not be able to
function this is really bad for them and
we have ill-served them
right which was a sound argument to make
in fact most of us probably would have
believed
it but the reality turned out different
what happened was the kids came out
they just brought the campus with them
and imposed it on the real world
and all the 50-somethings who supposedly
run the wheel real world
cow are in fear at the 20-somethings and
give them everything they want
right you used to see this at least
during the 60s when they were the campus
riots
usually the administrators pushed back
on them a little bit you know now
now it seems as though the
administrators were those radicals in
the 60s
it's not just campuses it's corporate
c-suites it's editorial boards of
mainstream media
i've talked to a number of people i know
who say you know well in two instances
so one guy was talking about silicon
valley another guy was talking about the
media he says
we're all terr you know all editors and
senior people in any kind of mainstream
media out there are completely terrified
of the 20-somethings on the staff
and i've talked to people who say all
silicon valley upper management is the
same way they've got all these
20-something coders and
you know compliance people and who know
app generators and they're afraid of
them
right you guys are billionaires and
literally in some cases and you're
afraid of
these your most recent hires of course
as as well they should be i mean these
these
these 20 somethings that really could
ruin their lives and
this occurred to me with all this
chatter about institutional racism or
systemic oppression or whatever term you
want to use it did occur to me
as you just said big tech mainstream
media hollywood
administrative government you know the
bureaucracy on and on and on every
single institution
is controlled by the left so if there's
institutional oppression you know i
don't think it's
necessarily our fault but but if you're
in this situation now where
you've basically got every single
institution stacked against you a
conservative has the white house doesn't
even really seem to matter all that much
what do we do because getting back to
something you said earlier
you've got this kind of woke crazy
ideology which is ironically just
an alternate version of john john
calhoun's secessionist ideology
uh we're we're also not going to go back
to this propositional
pure nation idea that america is just an
idea floating in outer space there's no
connection whatsoever
to like people and places and land so
then if we're conservatives
what are we for what what is the what is
the answer to this problem
well i mean the main question for any
conservative is what is it that you're
trying to conserve
and to me what we ought to be trying to
conserve is first and foremost the
american people
themselves their communities their
industries their churches their way of
life
as the chairman of the board of the
claremont institute has put it in a
couple of articles that have gotten big
attention
and a speech their way of life that's
what we should be trying to conserve
we've done a poor job of that in the
last generation at least
by being too reflexively um deferential
to market ideologies and things that
that rapidly um accelerate the
corrosion of these things we should be
trying to conserve so
um you know nietzsche's somewhere i
think this is in
uh twilight of the idol says you know
man unlike a crab cannot
cannot crawl backwards that's his
whisper to the conservatives
we're not going back to 1985 i use the
image in the book at one point
of back to the future which is a movie
that came out in 1985 and the whole
premise is
we're going to go back 30 years there is
a sense of back to the future
conservatism where they
conservatives ideal year is almost 1985
reagan was just re-elected we're about
to win the cold war the economy is
booming
you know think of all these great you
know we're about to put scalia on the
court um
you know what a great year for the
republicans and conservatives and i
agree
but we can't go back we've got to look
forward and so the reasons to hope
are the main reason to hope is that the
people who have not had their way of
life conserved
stood up in 2016 and said i'm not down
with this managerial bipartisan
oligarchic managed decline
yeah i'm not i'm i'm rejecting that and
i can think and hope
well those people will reject it again
in 2020 whether or not there are enough
of them to win the election we will find
out
you know either on november 3rd or a
week or a month or however long it takes
afterward to find out but they will vote
no again and even if they lose another
reason for hope is that
i do think we were we were discussing
before you know let's say they establish
blue woke tyranny
coast to coast how long can they keep it
going well
one destabilizing factor will be
when you lock 40 to 45 to 49 whatever it
is it's probably below 50 but it's a big
chunk of the american population who
supports trumpism and the president and
you know wants a kind of a different
way forward when you lock them out of
political participation and essentially
say
you can vote but it just doesn't matter
you're never going to get anything you
want we rule and we impose on you
that's a destabilizing situation that i
think
is a reason to believe they can't keep
their work tyranny going forever
it still may be a long time but that big
chunk of people
who don't like it and who are going to
be restless under it is a reason for
hope
that is that the fact that the if if
they do establish it that's not just
like going to ossify
forever because it's easy for
conservatives to think gosh we don't
control any of the institutions
49 ain't nothing to sneeze at i mean
that's a huge chunk of people
and they're not going to take it forever
obviously in 2016 that was a big
middle finger to the establishment
basically by voting for trump
so i i totally agree on the stakes of
all of this do you have any predictions
were
something like two weeks away at this
point how do you think the campaign is
going how do you think the
campaign to steal the election through
mail and
widespread unsolicited votes is going uh
you know it
how do you think it'll turn out well i
never make these kinds of predictions
because
uh yeah i just i never have a strong
feeling either way typically and i hate
to be wrong
you know i'd make a lousy tv pundit i
remember somebody telling me what they
were giving me advice on tv
no matter what question you're asked
here's the one answer you never give
what what is it
i don't know something well right i mean
i was convinced i will say this i was
convinced trump was going to lose in
2016-81
i am cautiously optimistic that he's
going to win in 2020 so take that for
what it's worth
i thought he won the debate last night
free handle
um yeah and i i just think
that when you look at um
his campaign energy his sort of closing
message the incoherence of biden's
message
the you know biden does want to go back
he doesn't want to go back to 1985 but
basically his pitch to the american
people is i'm going to take you back to
2015
yeah and then we're going to continue on
the same path we would have otherwise
been on had hillary won the 2016
election
except for the fact that i'm going to
put a bunch of woke crazies in charge
who are going to dial up the
malevolence insanity and revenge and
revenge plots
now that could win the election just
simply on sheer demographic strength
but friends of mine who watch the polls
carefully
say that it's very close in seven or
eight states
all of which could go for trump all of
which could go for by nor they could
split but that most of the time what
happens toward the end
is those last remaining undecided voters
or the last remaining you know close
districts
when they when they finally break one
way they all tend to like a flock of
birds they all tend to break in one
direction
and i you know my knock would hope is
that they
break in trump's uh direction and he
gets at least as many and maybe even a
handful more electoral votes than he got
last time
i definitely don't expect him to win the
popular vote uh i think the demographic
strength
in you know big vote bank places like
new york and california is just too
enormous for the uh uh the republicans
to overcome
although trump is correct to say that if
he were to campaign in california in new
york he could drive up his popular vote
totals in those states but not enough to
win those states so right
it's a total wasted opportunity and then
anything goes the one heartening thing i
think is
on the on the post-election night chaos
potential is
the left was openly talking about sort
of staging a coup
essentially and it got exposed it got
exposed by me
it got exposed by dan bongino it got
exposed by the guys at revolver news
and and many others it got pretty wide
play and they left finally realized that
uh maybe we should shut up
yeah and you haven't heard a lot of that
lately
so i i don't know that could mean i you
know i can't believe i'm about to say
this it sounds insane but that could
mean that they actually were chastened
for once
and backed down from uh a kind of
uh crazy anti-american threat that's the
craziest
that's the craziest thing you've said
during this entire interview the idea
that the left could be jason
yeah i knew i'd regret it you know
hillary clinton did say i mean she went
on tv and she said joe biden should not
concede
under any circumstances that is a
definitive statement
they have military officers writing a
letter to the well former but still
to the joint chiefs chairman saying
you've got to be ready to send the 82nd
airborne in to kick
the president this is really over the
top ugly histrionic
language that i at a minimum if they
weren't chasing somebody might have said
on a conference call this isn't playing
well yeah
we should cool it right right let's say
at least that
the same way don lemon famously said on
cnn i hope he's known for this quote for
the rest of his life the rioting has to
stop
it's showing up in the polling that's
right
guys listen i understand what you were
thinking but
now we we know that seven american
cities are burned to the ground
but the real problem is it's showing up
in the polls so you got to cut it out
that's right
uh those are the stakes you should all
go read the stakes the stakes america
at the point of no return you should
also read the rest of mike's writing i
mean
you have gotten a lot of this stuff
right when a lot of other people
said that anybody who saw anything in
trump was kooky
and unintelligent and stupid and racist
and bigoted and whatever else you know
you you were the one who had the guts to
put the put the essay out there
and so i would i would encourage you to
go check out claremont review books
check out
the american mind and go read mike's
book mike thank you so much for coming
on
thank you very much
[Music]
you